he is a guy that works for the pac-12
network with me for many years
uh but he's been somebody who's lived in
the bay area and been around
the san francisco 49ers organization and
those local
teams there for years runs a great
podcast the ham podcast with
uh john middle coffin himself my friend
uh guy haberman welcome to the show
what's up guy
leaf it's here it's here
that's the best way to put it guy and
i've been talking about uh
the nfl draft for months and months and
months because the pac-12 conference of
course didn't play a lot of football and
here we're at so
you've been in the mix right there and
you watched this move happen about a
month ago
and there's been speculation from the
moment it happened that it was mac jones
and they've gently seemed to shift a
little bit with the addition of john
beck as trey lance's
quarterback coach where where do we
stand and what do we expect
to happen tonight yeah i mean like you
said like most people i think know
mac jones is what a lot of people expect
i my expectation or my
my prediction a few weeks ago was trey
lance
and um there's a not there's a lot of
reasons not to
think that it's going to be trey lance
there's a lot of reasons not to think
it's going to be justin fields
i'm still open-minded tonight that it's
not going to be mac jones
i've gone this long without feeling like
i definitely know so why change now
but i do think kyle shanahan and john
lynch
spoke to the media on monday and uh it
was the second time they've
spoken since they did the trade they
also spoke a couple days
remember they did the trade on a friday
they spoke the following monday or
tuesday
and um i think both times they've talked
if we wait till tonight see who they
pick
and then go back and watch those press
conferences i think regardless of who
the pick is tonight we'll be able to
find
things in those press conferences that
we think were bread crumbs
to hint at who they ultimately take
but right now not knowing i think kyle
shanahan has left the most
bread crumbs for mack jones one thing he
has said
repeatedly in both press conferences
that he gave
is that yes of course you want patrick
mahomes
he said on monday yes ideally you'd have
drew brees's
uh you know passing pocket ability and
lamar jackson's legs
but when he says that he usually follows
up with some version of
but ultimately the best guys would have
been the best guys
in any era patrick mahomes and drew
brees as different
as they are are great now and they would
have both been great
40 years ago and they'll both be great
that version of a player 40 years from
now
and what he's saying when he says those
things is
i know what everybody tells me which is
that
the league is trending to play
quarterback
a certain way with athletic quarterbacks
but ultimately i'm not going to draft an
athletic quarterback
if i don't think he's as good as the guy
that is less athletic than him
so yeah of course i love mahomes he
spoke glowingly about josh allen last
year
before they played the bills but i'm not
going to draft that guy in place
because you tell me that's what the
trend is no the trend is
the best quarterbacks are the best
quarterbacks so my question is
is he saying that to make us think that
he's drafting mac jones or is he saying
that
because they're trying to get out ahead
of what's been i can't think of a
leaf i can't think of a uh
draft pick this high that everyone has
had such a negative
a fan base has had a negative opinion of
so quickly and it's really i feel
if it is mac jones i feel badly that mac
jones is walking into that because he'll
have to overcome that but
um that's where it stands i think kyle
shanahan has has
has left enough breadcrumbs on mac jones
the question is is he doing it to
mislead or is he doing it to prepare
we're talking with guy haberman pac-12
network announcer
uh host of the haberman and middle cough
podcast there in the local bay area um
that then leads to the atlanta falcons
and i think what
hinges on the rest of the draft and how
the other quarterbacks fall
in line if they don't trade out of that
spot with somebody who needs a
quarterback or if they take
the likes of kyle pitts the quarterbacks
could fall further and further down
where do the atlanta falcons go
uh if they've decided that matt ryan's
the guy did they stick with an offensive
player or do you think they trade out of
there to
to to put a team who needs a quarterback
to move up
this is what makes the mac the the third
pick so fascinating right
is like if the niners do take mack jones
does somebody love justin fields enough
to come up and take him
do the falcons like him enough to take
him i if if it were me i would not take
a quarterback there
if i were them um i would either move
back or take
you know kyle pitts i think new gm new
head coach
uh i don't want to make all my decisions
based on my job security but unless you
love the quarterback why start your
clock right now if you're those guys if
he's not going to start over matt ryan
and i think that's the interesting part
for the niners too is
like mac jones and justin fields
are guys that play right away trey lance
at least is viewed as a guy that doesn't
play right away
but i do think the 49ers want to trade
jimmy garoppolo i don't think they
want to play with jimmy garoppolo this
year i think they'd rather play with
whoever they draft and um i think it
makes sense for them to to trade him as
well like just to have that dynamic
um is not conducive to your new you know
franchise quarterback becoming the
leader of a locker room
um and that's the one part i've had a
hard time getting by when i talk about
lance is
that he's viewed more as a developmental
prospect but look
shanahan and this is not fair at rg3
what i'm about to say because rg3 was a
much better prospect coming out than
trey lance but
kyle shanahan won a bunch of games uh
won ten games
i think nine with rg3 as the starter his
rookie year
and he was the offensive rookie of the
year so i he
like i think even if it's lance he can
he can kind of uh
uh maneuver if you're the falcons to me
it's kind of weird unless it's lance
i know there's all the history with
justin fields in the state of georgia
but
um if i were them i you know i i don't
think they would take a quarterback just
given the way most
teams draft particularly in their first
years new head coach new gm that that
would be my guess there
all righty well let's uh let's get you
out of here with a little of our
our our weekly pac-12 talk all right um
the first player probably picked out of
the pac-12 is going to be pinnaesool
he's considered the
one of the best offensive lineman to
come out of college for some time yet
the cincinnati bengals are going to be
sitting there at at five
with every opportunity to draft somebody
to protect their franchise quarterback
joe burrow who they weren't able to do
what with what they weren't able to do a
year ago yet they are still enamored
by the possibility of that speedster
uh adonis of a wide receiver and jamar
chase reuniting him with joe burrow
what do you think the bengals should do
what do you think they do do i think
they should draft pine soul i think we
just saw the chiefs traded a late first
rounder
for a starting tackle um it
is orlando brown we see how difficult
the niners
had to go to the top of the market to
resign trent williams
it is so hard to find that guy last year
the first two rounds of wide receivers
drafted had a hit rate of like
nine besides jalen rager and uh henry
ruggs
every first and second round receiver
basically hit based on their value
of where they were drafted i mean it was
incredible what a good receiver draft it
was last year
now i don't think this draft has the
depth of receiver but it does at the top
mirror last year's draft i think the
tackles are hard to find i think you
draft a tackle every bengals beat writer
i hear and
listen uh i read and hear talk about
this thinks they're going to take
kyle pitts which ultimately i think is
good for
penne i i talked to penney yesterday he
does
he was very mom on the teams that like
him i think
there are teams that have told him they
like him and
he wants to go to those teams but some
things need to happen for him to get
there
um and i don't know miami might be one
at six but to me the chargers at 13
would make a ton of sense if somehow
they could get up to get him
and to me that feels like detroit spot
detroit has a one next year they have
they have two ones next year they have
two ones the next year follow miami's
blueprint
acquire picks move back so i think they
go chase at five
if penae ends up in miami that would
make sense but i i also think if if he
doesn't go to miami
at six then the chargers would make
sense for pine soul if they could move
up
well that'd be nice to reunite
quarterback
and offensively for him to go to the
chargers leaf of course i would i want i
you know what i i just i just need the
los angeles
chargers to win a super bowl and that
quarterback to be an mvp or something
like that and maybe then i'm not talked
about
as much as maybe that's the only reason
it's always about me
you spent too much time with me over the
last three years to know anything
different
guy haberman everybody everybody from
the pac-12 network my boy
check them out the haberman middle class
podcast you can
check them out on twitter and instagram
at guy haberman thanks for joining us
bud
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here